[Music]
what's up
everyone i'm persia and i'm here with
buddy
and we are reacting to the immortals
phoenix rising trailer
and i mean we haven't seen it yet but
let's go ahead and check it out right
now
let's get into it
oh hero landing yo this funky minotaur
is about to kill you
oh get him girl oh lightning hammer
powering up
and big boss battle with medusa
she is definitely got some tricks
she's the phoenix that rises i felt the
buildup like
in my heart right there
okay guys so that was the announcement
trailer now we have 11 minutes of
gameplay from ub forward so let's get
into that
the narrator starts out that this is a
tale of the gods told by the gods
themselves and at the end of the
gameplay
we see that zeus is standing in front of
prometheus we find out that
uh they're the narrators zeus is a
comedian apparently and and prometheus
is the uh street man
so a little bit of comedy to go with a
little bit of like the seriousness and
kind of having them both
almost feel like you know good and bad
on your shoulder
sounds really fun like prometheus typhon
is a titan
just this monster dude and he has
caused corruption throughout the land
you can see you know that red stuff is
the corruption of typhon and you can see
that like a lot of the monsters are
bearing like that red corruption as well
like typhon has got to
you know the cyclops and the the genies
and
and uh you see that minotaur it's
throughout the land and
phoenix is tasked by the gods to uh kind
of reverse some of that corruption
it's clear here that typhoon is upset
and the more we're taking people out the
more we're
getting rid of all of his little goons
he's just sending more
people after us and stronger people on
top of that
yeah i mean it says he's sending some
dead heroes after us and
i mean greek mythology is is so thick
with possible heroes
some of which were using their weapons
anyway so they might be more mad at us
if you look at the map you see that
there's a lot of like references to
greek mythology but they don't take
a lot of it seriously i mean the gates
of tartarus obviously tartarus is
is you know the underworld kind of thing
there's the valley of eternal spring
there's all these things that are like
potentially a direct reference to greek
mythology but slamming it all together
doesn't exist anywhere in mythology
you can see all of these little tiny
pieces that they've mixed
together to make this really cool place
that doesn't follow greek mythology
religiously
which is good it is good especially for
people
probably like me who don't know a lot
about it but are still very interested
in it
probably have played other games that
have some sort of greek mythology in it
but having this fresh take
and you can still enjoy the story for
what it is for its
new look on it uh mixed with the the art
style
i think it looks amazing i did read an
interview and
basically they they were inspired by a
lot of those early 2000s open world
platformers
the art style for them was said to be
like banjo-kazooie
meets studio ghibli i think that's cool
it's like kind of kind of painterly
and it kind of helps with the uh
features and themes of
you know helping gods all that stuff
because it's not too it's not taking
itself itself too
seriously but it's not cheesy they
showed like this panorama shot
of just the golden aisle and how
beautiful
it really does look and i think that's
really going to be enjoyable
when you're flying through each area
when you're trying to find certain
things in certain areas
it's going to be very easy to find and
you can also use that far side ability
to like you know look like deeper into
the landscape and stuff and then clearly
see that there's different areas
the forged lands uh are our festus's
area
and that's all you know you know metal
and fire and automatons and things like
that so each
area is going to feel super different
based on the god that area represents
and if you remember from the
announcement trailer we did see
that big volcano right and it kind of
looked like it was taking over the land
now that we're seeing some gameplay we
can definitely tell that it is taking
over
so i feel already like there's a lot of
pressure here
so in the gameplay trailer the first
mission
that we kind of see is you need to
reignite hephaestus forge
and ifestus was the god of like
blacksmithing and stuff so
we're we're going in and reigniting this
forge we have to fight
uh an automaton which is something that
hephaestus made
again it's like uh you know it's like a
robot but early robots they were talking
about robots
in ancient greece which i think is so
cool so the vault of tartarus are
probably my favorite things so far
personally because i love puzzles
obviously the combat is looking great
and stuff like that but adding this
element
where i have to use these same abilities
i would use in combat
for a puzzle is just really interesting
to me so they're testing your brains
and your brain and that is kind of what
it means to be
you know powerful right you're learning
skills and abilities and it's a kind of
a feedback loop where you may have used
them before but not in this way and then
you get back out of these vaults into
the
the golden isles the larger world of
golden isles and you're utilizing these
new
these new skills you know using the the
wings of daedalus
mixed with you know one of your other
abilities maybe so obviously once you
get through the puzzle
it's not for nothing your reward is
zeus's lightning and it levels up
phoenix's stamina which is really
important because she uses daedalus's
wings to fly
and that stamina meter kind of
determines how long she can fly
so the combat is uh it comes down to
three core weapons your
your sword your axe and your bow it
seems like you can play
the way that you want to play depending
upon what your play style is
your sword is in your axe or your you
know lighter attack weapons
and then your bow is obviously ranged
you have a lot of
these god power attacks that are that
are super deep in in
you know the mythology themselves you
can use athena's dash
apollo is the god of archery um
hephaestus we talked about him but he's
you know
you're using his blacksmithing hammer to
beat the crap out of stuff
it means that there's gonna be a lot of
variety when we actually
are fighting against certain bosses we
have a lot of utility we have movement
we have air combos we have ground combos
i'm really loving that they're
making these abilities complement each
other you're gonna feel
very god-like in this game because of
these abilities
and again you know upgrading all of them
is
going to be very deep in the mythos as
well i mean you get you get coins of
sharon
sharon is the the boatman on the river
of styx like the river that you know
transports
souls to the land of the dead adamantine
is the it's the metal that all the god's
weapons are made out of
um prometheus chains are made out of it
so you're using that to upgrade some of
these abilities as well i just think
it's so cool how deep the mythos is with
all of this stuff
so we saw in a few shots you know once
we're taking flight we see another
little birdie fly next to us but that's
actually
foss rose and that's not just a random
bird that is gonna be
our friend i mean i always love having a
good companion in every game
you know phosphorus has got my back yeah
phoenix being accompanied by a phoenix
is really cool
so you can actually summon phosphorus to
help you in combat as well so while the
bird looks
super pretty it actually is uh
tactically good for you as well
so the trials are
puzzles around the golden isles that
reward you
upon completion coins of sharon you know
you can go to the hall of the gods and
upgrade all of your
abilities with that currency so the
vaults of tartarus
give us zeus's lightning which increases
our stamina but if we want to increase
our weapon damage and you know
some of the other godly abilities we
have to pay the boatman as it were
and there are different types of puzzles
so i'm really
curious to see where it goes and to see
just how powerful
phoenix is going to be because she's out
there working look at her
pumping some iron she's glowing right
now she's got the juice
you know the 90s training montage
she's pumping iron she's pumping gold
actually
she's like making potions she's a
blacksmith phoenix is the total package
the hall of the gods actually has
something that definitely caught my eye
because i saw a little comb and a little
scissor
over there and it's aphrodite's beauty
chair
where you can customize your character
and this is the first time we kind of
get confirmation that you can make your
character
whoever you want them to be yeah
apparently you can be male or female
um and i mean you know you sit down in
aphrodite's beauty chair you're going to
look good
absolutely also at the hall of the gods
we can use adamantine to upgrade
some of our i guess armor maybe or or
some of our other things that we haven't
actually seen in this in this trailer
we're upgrading our skills
using the coins adamantines used to
upgrade some of the loot elements
so obviously i'm super excited about the
mythology
you're excited about the gameplay what
do you think how
how deep into this game are you going to
get it kind of hits
all of the boxes that i enjoy in a game
combat is looking smooth it's looking
versatile
it's in general looking very pretty
colorful
fresh it's giving me options to
customize it's giving me room for growth
it's kind of doing everything that i
like in a game
so i'm really really interested to see
or actually get my hands on it this
december
december 3rd